[Musique]
le mot coltan est une abréviation pour
colombie tente à l'it
on extrait deux matériaux de ce minerai
le tantale et aussi le niobium et le
tantale qui surtout prisé quand on
extrait du coltan ce métal a une très
grande résistance à la corrosion ou
l'utilisent entre autres pour fabriquer
des condensateurs les composantes que
l'on retrouve dans nos téléphones
intelligents nos ordinateurs et nos
voitures électriques
on retrouve du coltan dans plusieurs
pays du monde dont le canada l'australie
et la chine
mais c'est la région du kivu en
république démocratique du congo qui a
la part du lion
ces richesses ont toutefois un revers le
coltan est considéré comme un minerai
qui alimentent les conflits comme les
diamants du sang
les organisations non gouvernementales
qui travaillent dans la région du kivu
dont médecins sans frontières font un
lien direct entre l'exploitation des
mines de coltan et la violence dans la
région et le congo demeure l'un des pays
les plus pauvres du monde le pib par
habitant n'est que de 600 $ par année et
l'espérance de vie n'atteint même pas 60
ans